designing a small home is a challenge
for anybody even a fully trained
architect
however today i wanted to share with you
my 10 tips
on how you can design the best small
homes
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about small homes
small homes are generally defined
as a space that you have no space
it is a very challenging project and it
is always something that i look forward
to when it comes to designing
architecture today i wanted to share
with you my 10 best pieces of advice
for designing a small home or even
renovating your own small home
this way you can absolutely maximize the
space that you have been given the first
thing you need to remember is that space
is luxury you do not have a lot of space
to work with
so make sure that everything is planned
out perfectly
before you go ahead and start working so
if you're renovating a small home for
example you don't want to start on one
section
finish that move on to the next finish
that and move on to the next
you want to map out and plan out the
whole entire space
there isn't much to work with here so
that's exactly why you have to do
the whole thing at once if you're
designing a new small home on the other
hand
it takes a very very long time to plan
out
every single detail sometimes it takes
longer to design a small home that it
takes
to design an entire mansion so when it
comes down to designing small homes
always remember that every detail has to
be planned out
before you begin actually doing any work
the next element to remember is
storage is king storage is absolutely
everything in a small home so wherever
you can store something
make sure it is a storage container for
example
if you have a bed you can have it as a
gas lift bed which is storage underneath
or that same bed can be a murphy bed
that hides away
so you have additional space and
additional storage
any sort of tv cabinet bookcase shelving
unit
coffee tables even you have to select
the right furniture that creates its own
storage elements you don't want to go
out and purchase a nice big lavish
coffee table that looks phenomenal
but at the same time it just takes up a
whole
two square meters in your living room
and does nothing else but is a
placeholder
so you have to get very creative and
very clever
a coffee table shouldn't just be a
coffee table a bookshelf
shouldn't just be a bookshelf a bed
shouldn't just be a bed
you have to really carefully think about
every single piece of furniture
that is going into that house you also
have to think about
every structural element that's in that
house and how you can actually
utilize this space in there a good
example is i
beams and columns if you have a
beautiful column that
shapes right through the center of your
small home it's usually in the shape of
an eye
to simplify things you can utilize that
column and create
bookcases or shelves or any sort of
storage inside it
so it just isn't a random column in the
middle of your floor plan
or tucked away in the corner you have to
get as creative as possible
another scenario is under stair storage
if you have stairs raking up to a loft
you have to make sure you utilize
every step underneath because after all
that space underneath stairs
is wasted space unless you carefully
think about it you can easily create
that understeer storage into some sort
of additional room like a study nook
it really gives you the ability to
multi-purpose that space
which brings us on to our next point
multi-purpose rooms
a bed can be anything but a bed if it's
a murphy bed
it quickly hides away into a wall cavity
and it's disappeared so you can utilize
that space again
the underside of stairs can be converted
into a study nook so it isn't just a
bunch of dead space
walls can be operable they can be
sliding they can be moving they can be
corner fixed
whatever you can do to partition spaces
and create
an illusion of extra space this is what
you want to achieve with multi-purpose
design
so for example if you have two spaces a
living room and a bedroom
with a petition sliding wall in the
middle that murphy bed in the bedroom
could be pushed away and that entire
wall
could be slid across to the edge of that
room so all of a sudden
your living room isn't half the size but
it's the full size
you really have to think about all the
ways rooms can become
multifunctional and multi-purpose now
the next point is purely for inspiration
the japanese do incredible things with
small homes
so if you're looking for inspiration
make sure you research japanese
architecture
and japanese minimalism both of these
can truly redefine your space and
perception of what a small home could be
now when we start thinking about
traditional elements we have to scrap
that entire idea
every single door in your small home
should be sliding
they should slide into cavities and
pockets and they should slide
flush so when you push that cavity
slider
all the way into the wall there isn't
that standard 50 mil
recess that sits out so you can grab the
door there's a little hook
that pops out so you can take it you
want to be able to push that door as
far away as possible because if you
think about a traditional swing door
all of a sudden you have a square meter
in front of that door that's
absolutely dead space you can't do
anything with it
because the door needs to swing that
entire range of motion
whereas with a sliding door you don't
have that problem so
swing doors are a no go in small house
designs just like doors
windows are everything the more windows
you can utilize in a small home the
better
windows give you the optical illusion of
grandeur and space
with a small home it doesn't matter
where you place a window it is going to
be ideal
so think creatively about windows you
don't have to go and place a million and
one windows across the entire front
north facade
and just beacon that light into you you
can go with small highlight windows
or narrow skinny windows in order to
genuinely bring in a lot of
directed light and if you don't have
that ability to bring in natural light
through the external walls think about
the ceiling space and think about the
roof with small designs if you're
starting from scratch you want them to
be as high as possible
if you can utilize voids and space that
again
gives that grand feeling of space even
in a small confined environment
so having a double story void or having
a story
and a half where you can emulate a loft
on top is
fundamental in small designs by pushing
that ceiling height up
as high as possible you also get that
added benefit of creating the windows
in the ceiling so now you can implement
some skylights into your design
to genuinely let that natural light flow
through
and fill it with light the more light a
small home has
the bigger it looks the less light it
has the smaller and confined it looks
so you definitely want to try get as
much light in through the walls
through the ceiling and by having as
much space
for that light to come into now if you
do have an abundance of natural light
coming in
from every direction you don't want to
have a dark moody small home
it just can't be done effectively i'm
sure people have tried it
but i guarantee you if you have a light
vibrant
small home it's always going to look
bigger it might appear like an optical
illusion but light reflects better
off light colors it isn't absorbed into
the darkness
so by having light bright walls either
whites light grays light beiges any
timeless color you can think of
it is always going to appear bigger so
you never want to go with the dark
colors no matter how trendy they are
no matter how much you love them you
want to stick to the light bright colors
and finally you do not want to feel like
you're tucked away in a small home
you always want to have some sort of
connection to nature
greenery is pivotal in any small home
design
a pot plant here and a pot plant there
is all well and good but you really want
to try create that
indoor outdoor connection so think about
the window seals think about the outside
of the building how it can be created
and pushed back inside the building if
there's an ability to create a planter
in front of one of your main windows
then you can easily replicate nature
coming out of the ground
and into the home it is a well
researched statement that greenery and
nature
genuinely makes people happier singapore
for example is
trying to improve their forestry in
cities by
doubling it as much as they can every
single year
to ensure people have a genuine sense of
happiness
so living in a small home living in
something that you might feel
claustrophobic in
you do want to emulate as much nature as
possible to really trigger
those psychological emotions you want to
stay happy in your home
you want to stay healthy in your home
and you want to genuinely love it as
much as possible
anyway that's all for me today guys i
hope this advice helped you on your
small home design journey or on your
renovation journey
small homes are a challenge take as much
time as you need
and make sure you master plan everything
anyway that's all for me today guys
thanks so much for watching i hope you
enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and because
this video forms one of my 28 videos in
28 days
it would usually be i'll see you next
monday but in this case
i'll see you tomorrow